so herzlich willkommen bei wwm wer weiß
mehr den beliebten chris blight klicks
um
unsere gäste heute die außenseiter hallo
das heißt es gibt heute nur fragen zum
thema die außenseiter wir wollen also
wissen ob ihr euch da wirklich richtig
auch das gut was bekommt der gewinner
wir kommen nur zur ersten frage ihr seid
vorbereitet konzentriert ich hoffe ja
unter eurem ältesten video auf dem kanal
die außenseiter ein sehr böser traum
sind momentan kann sich natürlich ändern
heute am 20 april wie diese machen sind
momentan wie viel video antworten
gepostet
das ist ja mal ne frage ja
es gibt ja die antwort a
3 ein video antworten b9 video antworten
c12 video antworten oder die 33 video
antwort die
b33 video antworten unter eurem ältesten
video
es gibt ihnen die antwort ich schätze
mal die ich würde diese 33 was würdest
du sagen ihr müsst euch einige führte
einigen muss eine antwort sein na ja ihr
könnt nur einen abhängigen ja dann
machen wir die ich weiß es nicht der 33
sollte das wirklich ein worden seit er
ganz sicher ich würde euch auch weil die
chance das ist schon voll als ich habe
schon lange nicht nur drei bis heute
löschen ja auch mal wieder nicht jeden
tag aufs video
ich glaube sogar 12 wir könnten dann 50
50 joker machen
lasst uns einigen
ich habe meine zwölf im kopf
also bei betreten sich auch wenn ok das
okay wir noch keinen 33 ins lager falsch
habe ich gewusst das sind 99
das hätten wir sowieso nicht gewusst na
ja gesagt 12 das ist eine extrem schwere
frage bei den einmalerlägen kompletten
mal einmal einmal einen fehlversuch
hatten bei
290 videos oder so so die anzahl von
video endlosen zu wissen
da muss man schon die kopie der serie
natürlich dass
wir hatten ja ich glaube ihr habt glaube
ich keine ahnung von euch
da muss man schon kaputt im konzern um
die anzahl versicherter
gut jetzt kommt eine frage die sich ja
viel einfacher und mich auf keine zahlen
also bei amazon gibt es ja ein buch
käuflich zu erwerben das buch überleben
unter opfern so und jetzt gibt es ja
immer die rubrik kunden die diesen
artikel gekauft haben kauften auch
welche artikel den ich euch jetzt
vorlege vorlese ist dort aufgeführt die
tribute von panem zwei gefährliche liebe
b
berlin gesichtsmassage bürste c der boss
von moritz netenjakob
jakob ein sehr guter comedy autor dann
oder die die kunst des klaren denkens 52
denkfehler die sie besser an das anderen
überlassen
was war das mit der bürste noch nie
berlin gesichtsmassage wirst du wirst
ein bisschen kauft also aber sind ja
mehrere bücher die der jack aber nur
eins von diesen artikeln ist darunter
panja nicht so weil guck mal in dem film
kommt vor
magst du dir außenseiter kommen so eine
stelle von magst du dir außenseiter und
dann sagt dann sagt die frau ja neben
der außenseite oder so was ähnliches das
muss schick sein okay also was macht er
denn jetzt ein a b oder c ja ich trete
ja nicht baby also gesichtsmassage
möchte oder nicht dabei hätte ich gerne
so eine gesichtsmassage ist also was
wirkt er jetzt sein
mein gott ihr pfeifen seit ihr schlecht
es ist natürlich
berlin gesichtsmassage
gesichtsmassage allem ja schreibt in
seinem buch
was gibt noch die dritte aber ihr seid
wirklich sehr schlecht aber guck mal wie
ihr seid richtige außenseiter zu unserer
verteidigung das sind echt fragen zu
leuten die sie selbst noten zu
selbstverliebt sich selbst interessieren
wer
als nächstes ist man ganz einfach das
müsst ihr wissen ja
ganz einfach
wie viele worte stehen in diesem buch du
willst es war
also an
also a 17.000 verbracht
624 1784
730 1257
das ist in den ticket
ich habe
mich also wie viel dort wollte sich
jetzt da a17 1163 b74
24087 1207 fertig
ihr müsst wissen wie viel wollte er so
ich weiß nicht mal wie viele bilder drin
sind aus welchem grund sollten
wir haben ja nicht dabei
zeichnen würde ich nicht alles wissen
also haben wir irgendein vermutung
also er sagt c37 1247
ich will jetzt wollen wir hier nicht als
absoluter verlierer aus eben wenigstens
einen punkt 17.000 ich sag's 17.000
guten
gewissens abbe 24.000 784
37.000
124 77 84 oder zu lenken und ist über 10
37 207 presse.de 24/7 finanzieren
das waren 17 das ist leider falsch ihr
seid die ersten
die keine frage richtig beantworten ist
es c37 1247 aber das ist auch etwas
gutes
trotzdem für euch welches der beiden
clixoom stern weil es so viel spaß
gemacht hat und was bekommen die gewinne
sie bekommt was du auch aber ihr habt
social media receiver außenseite ist
mittlerweile bei dem man auch mal die
moral der geschichte ist egal wie
schlecht man im leben ist bekommt das
gleiche
die moral gesiegt hat sich außenseiter
er müsste ja verlieren um den preis zu
kriegen genau die haben das extra
gemacht
ja ich hoffe ich habe nicht zu viel
versprochen das war wwm mit den
außenseitern
etwas besser schneidet zb ali dabei ab
der weiß hier unten jetzt verlinkt der
weiß eine menge mehr übersicht und auch
ganz gut informiert ist natürlich hans
dabei also dabei auch viel spaß aber er
muss schon ein wenig überlegen also
schaut selbst hier jetzt unten irgendwo
da verlinkt wwm mit den beiden
entscheidet euch
ich hoffe dadurch leicht fallen bis dann